[Music]
my name is Yu Feng whoa
welcome to the devs own and I'm joined
today I'm in house cause II you think is
developer at look at for machine
learning and out AI and I'm developer
advocate for Google Data studio and
today we're going to talk about from
data to dashboard a machine learning
adventure so the way it started is most
of the time you thinking I decided that
we're going to build a company some kind
of a maybe call it a startup perhaps
yeah so we'll have a startup now even
works in machine learning
I work in data vis so we thought can we
put these two together and maybe create
a company and then make lots of lots of
money some kind of a successful company
yes like a start-up yes some kind of a
startup some kinds yeah that would be a
good idea now um but what are what is
this company going to do like what are
we going to sell what are we going to
make just gonna just throw some ml and
data visualization at it it'll be fine
right like we need to look at how we can
yes how we can make a turbo and cab you
later if anyone heard of a turbo and
calculator it's because typically I got
I got a spec here it's based on the
principle of data generation by the
motio interaction of magnetic reluctance
and capacitive reluctance and the ml and
turbo and calculator will negate the
relative motion of conventional
conductors and fluxes what yep
okay let's just move on yeah so what is
our plan
so we'll collect some successful
information some information about
successful companies from all over the
US and we're gonna try to emulate
successful companies that's what
everyone does right we try to emulate
those that are successful and we'll
analyze that data we'll do some machine
learning try to come up with things like
what should we call a company who should
win our company maybe where do we want a
company to be and hopefully we'll have
some profit with our turbo and cab you
later alright so this is the data set we
started with right we use the Inc 5000
data set of America's top growing
companies where there was data available
for the first top 5,000 companies that
had the highest growth rate over three
total three years and this is what the
data kind of looks like it had
information on the year the company was
founded the rank of the company on the
growth chart then the name of the
company where when it was founded which
location it was founded in the state the
revenue amount and also the growth
amount the industry and the hit
headcount yeah and we were looking at
this we're just thinking like hmm maybe
maybe we can get something out of this
to get some insights about what makes a
company successful right is it these
factors or is it something that's not
necessarily captured in here so so this
is a big list right it's over nine of
5,000 it's not like thousand wrote about
if the company lists or a hundred
company lists we have 5,000 companies
that's some really big data yes and for
very big data we need big firepower
that's right and that means to to search
through this big 5,000 long list we need
some big queries as well right so we
decided to put our data into bigquery
and so we will put our 5,000 rows in
bigquery and run queries on it run
analyzes and figures try to figure out
what makes this company
is successful so the data we had we took
the data and we put it into bigquery and
then we try to see what kind of visual
insight we could get out of it so to get
the visual insight what we did is we use
data studio to connect to the bigquery
data set and then take the data and sort
of get some kind of insight out of the
data so to do that we went to data
studio we selected the bigquery we
picked our data set and then we
connected to it so once you connect to
it it kind of gives you the overview of
the data as you can see this is the what
the data looks like the inter scheme of
the data and then once we connect to the
data set it gives us a blank canvas
where we can create our viz so let's try
to create our first base we'll try to
add a bar chart and we'll try to see the
average revenue of companies so I'll try
to find by industry the average revenue
and you can see there's a zero here zero
means for these companies the industry
was not defined so let's try to filter
that out so we'll add a custom filter
and we'll create a new filter will say
exclude all industry that is basically
zero we save that and you can see that
the security industry has the most
highest average revenue per company it's
because they're all securing that
revenue right yeah they're very secure
about their revenues and also the
logistics and transportation because
they are transporting their revenues
exactly so we'll try to add maybe one
more chart and try to look at how the
exact number or maybe how the number of
companies look like across states so
we'll add the state variable and
and the rank or maybe record count so
how many companies are there from that
list in each state and let's apply some
filters and as we view the dashboard we
can see most of these companies are in
California then in Texas Florida if we
try to let's say filter down if we click
on Virginia it shows us that in Virginia
insurance companies are doing the best
and followed by government services
which makes sense because it's close to
DC exactly and what I really like about
this is that you were able to make a
auto filtering interactive chart yeah
without having to do any sort of like
coding to make that clickable filtering
work exactly and we did completely
serverless completely on google cloud
yeah because the data was in bigquery
and the VIS is being done in unison with
you you can just use from your browser
yeah super handy just like bing bang
boom so we use this visit and created a
dashboard beforehand this is what the -
were sort of looks like on the left side
we have number of companies by industry
and then we have number of companies by
state in this your chart we're showing
the average state of the companies that
are coming up in this filtered view when
did the company start and there's also a
sort of an insight from what are the
outlier companies so we have the top 100
ranks here and the revenue of the
companies and we can see that there are
three outlets here the first one is
carvanha then the second one here is a
bond and we have another play here which
is the Panther X specialty pharmacy yes
and we can even filter it here if we
click on health it will filter across
all of the other charts and show you a
filtered view of the entire data so from
this - when we try to figure out which
industry should we be in which state
should we be in so it looks like
California is the state where we have to
be in because most of these successful
companies are there so if we've found if
we establish our company in California
we have a very good probability of being
successful that's right because
correlation is causing
exactly so that was our dashboard now
the most important decision we had to
make about our company can anyone guess
what was the most important decision
very did location
we already did industry kind of right
what are the things what other factors
are there what is the single-most name
yeah I heard name a couple of times what
should we call our company right
it's got to be catchy it's got to make
sense but be a little bit edgy right and
so how can we make this make this
critical decision oh we'll look to our
data we got 5,000 companies and we can
take that and we can stick it into a
machine learning model that will
actually generate us names that are
similar to these companies right we want
to be like them we want to be like the
top 5,000 companies and so you know if
you could have a lot of options right
how to do this basically what we did was
you took that bigquery data pulled out
that column put it into collaboratory
and ran a recurrent neural network to
make those generative models and we spit
out some very interesting company names
and what's neat about this I found was
that with generative models you can set
what's called a temperature and the
temperature determines how kind of
creative the model decides to be how
hacky it decides to be and on one in the
spectrum you have extremely normal names
moins that show up repetitively or words
that are very common and so they're kind
of safe and on the other side of the
temperature spectrum you have really
really creative names you might happen
well what might be viewed as
misspellings but sometimes that's a good
thing for companies and you might have
things that just make no sense at all
and then in between you have kind of in
between stuff and so looking at this
list which ones do you think are real
companies that really exist out in the
world and which ones were just
completely made-up which is generated
from the model hey can you tell them
apart
let's take the first one how many people
think the first one is a real company
personally Sophie and motors mudras how
many people think it was generated all
right okay what about the second one the
lowly Cup USA is it how many people
think it's real well a cop USA is real
okay all right I thought the USA is fake
so about half and half on that one
interest rate we can do the third one oh
yeah they do the third one yeah per soft
real are soft fake another 50/50 cool
who didn't vote okay alright let's let's
go on and take a look so I guess we
should give it away now the left side
are all fake and the right side are all
real so lollipop is real purse off this
fake and say but it's about cuz the
volume is also real it's also real yeah
and so here are some other names that we
generated in addition to those and we've
kind of colored it by this temperature
metric so at the top of the list are
fairly creative company names now
remember these are all fake not a single
one of these companies is real okay and
then at the bottom our names that are
really safe similar and you can see
there's a little bit of a pattern it
seems that company is really like to
call themselves solutions or systems or
services right and they want to cover
all the things so that gives us an idea
that we will call our company all system
solution services trademark pending will
be most successful company name ever it
will be instantly recognizable and
etched into the minds of our customers
definitely alright so this leads us to
the other question right aside from the
name of the company is whose name will
be in that CEO slot who should run the
company well we can use the same
technique as we did before and try to
make up some names to we got a list of
5,000 founders and they're all in the
top 5,000 companies in
so again who's real and who doesn't
exist
raise your hands if you think Andy
Guerin is a real person who runs a
company in the top 5,000 who thinks that
Andy garand does not exist it's totally
made up okay
quite a few people think yeah and he
doesn't exist or Andy
how about Jeff Shaw Jeff is real Jeff is
not real all right
I think people are catching on yeah well
we got to look at the other side though
right what about Dwayne Smith is Dwayne
Smith a real person
okay and Dwayne Smith is completely
made-up computer-generated name so we
gotta really wake people up somehow we
don't have any cupcakes if there are you
unfortunately but I know it's still
technically morning so again the left
hand side is fake and the right-hand
side is real so the Wayne Smith is real
Jeff Hall is fake and we can see some
other examples of names we have some
more creative names toward the top that
are not some of them you know like the
first one you know what what the last
name fr and I a little short on the
vowels and the letter ordering but for
the most part these names kind of sound
real for the most part right especially
the ones in Italy they start you know
yep it's not the worst they seem like
people name of real people yeah so
apparently the people like the name Jeff
yeah I think we should be hiring like
Jeff gardener and or maybe Chris Martin
to run the company yeah but but they
don't exist so we can't hire them yes I
know what we should do let's change our
names
you can name yourself Jeff and I can
call myself Chris all right so nice to
meet you Chris all right nice to meet
you Jeff so that way since we've changed
our names and we have these names the
model / dates that our company will be
successful absolutely successful name
successful names yes
so this brings us to the next question
of you know we don't just want to be in
the top 5,000 we want to be toward the
top of the top 5,000 right and so oh so
let's take a look at how we might go
about doing that so I've got the data
right we dumped it out of bigquery I did
like a little bit of cleaning up on big
gray and the screen okay did a flash and
so we'll import tensorflow and caris and
in this case you know I'm pulling into
pandas and what I'm gonna do is we'll
try to take some of the statistics that
are coming out of this data set and load
it into a Karass model to basically try
to build a model that can predict which
quintile the given a given company will
be falling in given things like what
stated in the growth percentage
headcount numbers in its industry and
its revenue and so you know I've
processed out like the quintile so I
added the quintile column in bigquery to
basically do a division by thousand and
then you know we can see some
interesting statistics about our columns
like there's you know 26 unique
industries in this data set we've got 52
States thanks to Puerto Rico and
Washington DC and we have let's see when
the other notables the ranges of the
revenue I found to be pretty interesting
I know it's written in scientific
notation so apologies in advance but the
minimum threshold to make this 5,000 the
lowest revenue annually was 1.7
basically million dollars so these are
not the smallest companies but then when
you get to the higher end you know four
point seven times ten to the ninth is
for bromelia 7 billion dollars in
revenue and these are all privately held
startups so we'll we split the data up
into training and test and here I've
actually split it in half just because
we only have 5,000 companies I'm not
gonna show them model all these
companies then I have nothing to do
predictions on so I just show
and we'll save have to use and make some
predictions on at the end then we'll
grab our you know or the columns we want
split them down and then I've got my
training input functions etc and then I
what I've done here is used tensor flows
feature columns which is a way to kind
of do some feature engineering I find
that having the right tool for the right
tasks is really important in bigquery
making an extra column for quintiles and
doing a little bit of like date
manipulation was really easy and so I
did it there because it came to mind but
then as I went through the process and I
wasn't and doesn't know doing stuff to
things there those were like the
discoveries I made there around what I
needed to do I could just do them right
then and then when I actually started
loading it into the model I realized hmm
you know things like growth it's just a
number and the growth kind of ranges all
over the place so I took the quintiles
the 24 the percentiles the 25th
percentile the 50th percentile and the
75th 70 75 % percentile values for some
of these columns and bukka ties them so
that you know because I don't care if
the growth is 40 percent or 50 percent
like that's roughly the same thing and
so I want the model to recognize it as
such I've done the same thing here with
head count and with revenue and revenue
is especially notable because the ranges
are kind of all over the place and so
knowing where the percent house are
helps you get a nice even distribution
of your data across the buckets and so
with all the feature columns set up I
made two different models a linear model
and a deep learning model right so the
linear model did pretty good I'd say all
things considered when I finished
evaluating we came out to about 76
percent accuracy I could keep training
longer I could eat you know bang my head
against the different features and
different columns add more data but all
things considered you know given that
the insider piece here was when I first
started doing this I didn't have any
buckets at all I was getting like 20%
error
accuracy which is terrible right so the
changes really made a meaningful
difference and on the deep model side I
just kind of made a simple model it's a
three layer model
with 15a 2015 and 10 neurons per layer
so not terribly large not terribly
sophisticated but with that and training
for the same amount of time 86 percent
so still not perfect I'm not looking for
perfection here but just seeing if we
can actually model this behavior and it
seems like we can we can use information
like headcount location revenue and what
else growth percentage things like that
to actually predict you know the
successfulness of a given company and so
here we have a few see I already said
this part up so we have the different
industries just on the type in them all
so if we want we can actually generate
our own fake company we can say I want a
company that's in you know the state of
Maryland and has had a growth of two
hundred and three percent your over the
past three years I have doubled over
three years pretty reasonable for a
start-up sure maybe I've but I've only
got like 58 people hiring has been a
little bit slow and let's see what
industries should we be in does anyone
have a preference feel free to shout it
out
human resources okay so we'll be in
human resources where is human resources
here we go so we'll copy that and we'll
put that down here in our industry array
okay so human resources and how much
revenue do we want to have so we know
that on the low end of things is about
1.7 million and on the high end other
things we have about 4 billion so
depending on whether you believe revenue
is a big indicator for growth and
success of a company with only 58 people
how much revenue can we really be
expected to pull in 100 million a
hundred million what is that to the 8th
yes all right
so we'll say this much whoop good enough
I love the present all right still
remember how to use the computer that's
good
okay so that's a 100 million right to
the yep all right so let's run that and
see then we can think the where's the so
for actually a hole right but I'm
writing it to a file now alright so
we'll just write those results to the
file I don't know if that's gonna work
though so this is going to predict where
this company is going to end up in in
the ranking which quintal this it will
be among the first 20 percent or the
next 20 percent it will predict that
yeah that's cool so then we can
potentially predict that if we have a
company that's founded in California has
a growth of 5000 percent has only two
headcount we could try to predict if we
are going to end up in the first
quintile yeah I mean that kind of sounds
like the early days of Google a little
bit right are the early days of all
system solutions they're all system
solutions yes thank you definitely yeah
and so so what we've actually gone ahead
and done is we took the other half of
the data and I ran it through our our
model and we output it a CSV and pass
that over to Google sheets to Shannon
from Google sheets we have this data
which shows the comparison of the actual
versus predicted values
we're trying to click but it is alright
yep came up
so this data set basically shows what
was the actual values of the comparison
and then what did it prep what is the
predicted Bella is waiting for cash
waiting for the Wi-Fi is loading so as
we did that we have the actual value and
the predicted value we try to take this
data set and try to see that can we
visualize this again so we again went
back to data studio and then we added
back the data and try to visualize that
and you can connect data sphere
dashboards to a Google sheet so that we
did exactly that here we've connected
the dashboard to that comparison data
sheet and let's say we will add a new
chart and we will add a
when our company gets up and running
we'll have to fix our Wi-Fi that's right
yes so tell our employees to stop
streaming movies well we're presenting
and have that
now so this is our actual quintile and
predicted quintile and you can see the
comparisons come up and since this model
was pretty accurate for most of the
companies this is exactly the same now
we can try to add filters here and try
to see can we find something where these
are not equal so let's say we will try
to filter by state view this dashboard
and we should be able to then filter it
and see whether there are other datasets
where these don't match up so if we
filter for Virginia only we got we have
a lot of West Coast love so we'll do a
little East Coast yeah it's still mostly
the same so maybe there's one or two
hidden in there yeah so that being said
we saw we showed you how we can take the
outputs off we off the model and then
publish the insights using it is for
your dashboard and you can then take
this dashboard and then you can share it
with other people you can publish it and
embed it on websites so you can go from
completely a blank data set like a new
data set to a published dashboard
results in a few minutes in a few clicks
in a completely serverless environment
so that's basically tells us like our
company will be called all system
solution services we'll be creating and
soon to be in the Inca 5000 yes and so
so yeah thank you so much for coming
my name is Yu Feng this is the minhas
and yeah well I guess we are all system
solution services yes
trademark copyright registered ending
[Music]